your should feel like
they're going over
waterfall you have to do that your arm
comes in here and you've used uh the
say cheating te
cheating here to
here
this should go to the back of my leg so
this one to the back of my
leg used to say don't do this once you
see his hand do that but it's only
because you're sort of following
through but you do get in a habit of
doing that and adding a bit of that it
shouldn't so it should be here down
over to the back of the leg that's
there so look reason I'm saying this is
because most of you
doing this this and this arm coming in
front getting rid of them with that arm
so you're ending up like that that's
where
it's you know where it's
right it's
I remember Richard s saying I don't like
this one what I'll do if you do
it it's because UK should feel like
they've got no choice it's not
frightening for them but it's like over
water and I'm the same I never used to
like many people throwing me Kos know if
you I had some teachers that where when
you've got no choice and you're through
the
air you you know you're down you're up
before you know it so you haven't really
got time to think was it what did that
feel like cuz it this was a li it was
done so don't take the unless you enjoy
it but those who are getting it now arm
mustn't come in front arm must go to
the the back if you look in the those
have got my book if you look in the book
it'll show you a lot about this poan
where this
this mustn't help the
flick just does
that okay this
foot okay